[Music]
my name isan and I came after mommy and
daddy paid off all of that debt in
person PR we talked
about is any of this good or no does he
is it okay if he's not in the shot or
should I just wait wait
[Music]
okay I'm Aaron Littles and this is my
awesome wife mine Littles and we are
coming to you from Tampa Florida I
didn't learn a lot about money growing
up I just knew that we didn't always
have enough I had a upbringing where I
knew I wanted to have more but I didn't
know how and so I went into the Marine
Corps after graduating from the Naval
Academy and they just load you up with
credit cards to get you on your way and
start establishing your credit and uh I
did what Dave Ramsey said not to do
which was buy a house in everyday City
you're stationed in I look up and I have
a good paying job I'm serving my country
but but then I realized I'm way in the
hole in real estate debt and the
recession started to happen and you know
renters started leaving and then now I
get other credit card debt to just float
these houses for a while and I was like
this is not how how it's supposed to
work and so that's when I hit my turning
point to say I've got to do something
different and then he met
me I took out loans to cover everything
for grad school including my housing
around
$80,000 I was working for the government
at during the day and I was getting
second jobs and side jobs at night and
instead of putting that money towards
paying down the mountain of debt I just
apparently went shopping more when I
helped mine calculate her individual
budget I think that kind of opened her
eyes to see that she's working two jobs
but because of all the debt and the
spending patterns she was in the
negative every single month and not
actually even at zero I knew that I
needed to change something but to see it
all on paper like that was pretty
overwhelming he was like oh hey here's
this guy he's going to tell us how to
get debt free but you're going to have
to sell your car as soon as we get
married and I was not I was not at all
receptive to that and he said just
listen to this podcast and that's all I
ask and I was like fine and I listened
to it and it was a number of different
families that called in and talked about
how the grass in their backyard felt
much different because they had paid off
their homes and it resonated with me and
so that was when I was like okay let's
talk about this maybe we will sell my
car hopefully we won't but that was my
Turning Point really because he just he
changed his
approach once we got uh engaged we got
enrolled in FPU as part of our
premarital counseling sure enough we did
every single week and and paid attention
and and saw the immediate transformation
of having a zerob based budget and then
starting to really pay down debt the
first year we were getting out of debt
we paid off
$35,000 the second year I had an event
planning business on the side and then
we were really sticking to the budget
using the envelope system and we were
actually coordinating and helping lead
others and so whenever you do that
you're always holding yourself
accountable too to making sure that
you're following the program just as
much as you're expecting other people to
follow it and so that second year paid
off $775,000 in debt Madam was able to
leave a job that she didn't really enjoy
which is never something I ever
considered because I thought I would be
paying off my student loans until I was
50 this is what we've been able to do
and now people are coming up to us and
saying we saw you do it we know it's
achievable the underlying is that they
may find Jesus too and they may get a
personal relationship and that's always
even more special for us we paid off
$115,000 in 2 and 1/2 years the vision
of Freedom at the end and the
possibilities of what our family could
look like what our family could do for
the kingdom of God and what we would be
enabled to do was what kept us going
getting to the Finish Line was the goal
and we weren't going to stop and and she
married a marine and we just don't quit
so let's hear a dead free Scream 3 2 1
we're
[Applause]
[Music]
dead
[Applause]
[Music]
oh